c'est la vidéo qui tourne depuis
dimanche sur les réseaux sociaux cette
violente agression qui s'est passé en
pleine rue
un jeune homme de 17 ans a été
violemment passé à tabac celle d'une
agression survenue à montgeron dans
l'essonne
les faits remontent au 30 septembre
dernier
minutes on y voit un jeune homme roué de
coups par une dizaine d'individus sans
que personne ne lui vienne en aide la
victime âgée de 17 ans dénonce une
agression à caractère homophobe on a
désormais la certitude qu'il s'agit bien
d'une agression à caractère homophobe
mais quels sont les réels motifs de ce
lynchage qui sont les agresseurs que
s'est il réellement passé ces derniers
jours d'autres agressions visant des
représentants de l'état ont lieu dans
les banlieues que ce soit des
professeurs
ou même des forces de l'ordre
alors les banlieues sont elles devenues
incontrôlables serré les shérifs désolé
vous êtes sérieuse est beaucoup mais bon
on est content de vous avoir les
banlieues sont elles devenues
incontrôlables alors on alexandre
langlois policiers et candidat à la
présidentielle et alors là tout le monde
parle de vous enfin du coup je vais
apporter une précision à monsieur
montiel bon il est pas si ces messieurs
castaner où monsieur darmana que d une
information qui est fausse oui parce que
vous étiez d'affreux oui voilà alors
alors du coup je donnais pas présente
aux législatives
oui parfaitement avant j'étais au
syndicat de l'unige et gravité par
jacques chirac aimait donc c'est vrai ce
que j'ai dit mais je suis plus et j'ai
depuis chez elle après c'est sûr j'ai
bâti mettez vous en avez fait partie
alors j'en ai fait alors vous aussi vous
avez fait partie de tf1
c'était vraiment intéressant parce qu'il
a dit que vous n'aimiez pas d'étiquette
vous attend ce n'est pas l'étiquette
vous allez y à plus d'éthique a plus
rien debout dit jacques chirac n'était
pas la france
ces bons appelé le las il est sur la
chaîne animaux pour le trouver merci on
va revenir sur tout ce qui s'est passé
parce que vraiment ça a été extrêmement
durs un set cette vidéo qu'on a vu merci
aurélien tâcher d'être là merci merci
députés les nouveaux démocrates nicolas
dupont aignan merci d'être là député de
l'essonne et président de debout la
france et juliette brille brille hans
graf briens excusez moi vous êtes
influence us patriot salsa est on avec
nous heureux d'avoir nino comment savoir
moulineaux ça va ça va bien alors tu vas
nous raconter toute l'histoire parce que
toi tu as tué non mais c'est vrai que
j'ai vue arrive peut arriver cinq
minutes après cette affaire ouais c'est
un deux minutes exactement tu va nous
raconter toute l'histoire puisque toi tu
es tu es un jeune qui arrivait sur les
lieux quelques minutes après l'agression
et tu es aussi un grand frère abbas est
ce que tu nous a dit on va dire ça voilà
bah on va dire ça d'accord pas situé
dans le ve arrondissement
sis à tout va ça me gave croissance en
asie alors on va revenir sur cette
agression c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable elle a tourné toute la
journée on s'est dit comment cela pue
peut arriver tu vas tout nous raconter
comment est parti cette agression
regardez c'est un jeune homme de 17 ans
qui a été violemment attaqué par une
dizaine de jeunes en pleine rue c'était
le 30 septembre dernier à montgeron dans
l'essonne regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai que c'est
insupportable c'est fou mais fallait
qu'on vous les montre forcément on va
voir qu'est ce qui s'est réellement
passé ninon parce qu on a parlé de tout
tarifs déjà sur les lieux de l'agression
on a parlé d'une agression homophobe qui
va tout nous raconter mais qu'est ce qui
est passé de tarifs sur les lieux toi tu
arrives dix minutes après c'est ça ouais
donc là j'ai eu des petits lacs italiens
que son faux faut préciser que ce sont
les jeunes ils ont 14 15 ans d'accord ça
expliquerait un n'ont pas commencé par
dire ça mais bon moi je les ai vu leur
monnaie ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
passé parce que j'ai entendu des cris il
y avait énormément de créer environ
maintenant la rue j'ai vu pas la dame
qui séparait elle est en train de crier
sur eux donc je leur ai demandé ce qui
s'est passé assurément simplement
expliqué qu'en fait ça n'a rien à voir
avec une agression homophobe ça c'est la
première chose sur laquelle est ce que
c'est ce que tu veux mais alors que pas
du tout ça n'a rien à voir avec une
agression homophobe c'est quelque chose
qui a été mal on va dire mal transmis
c'est quelque chose que je reviendrais
dessus après le mal appréhendé tu va
nous raconter ça a été très mal
interprété d'accord oui mais concernant
l'histoire en fait c'est les jeunes
étaient dehors tout simplement les
jeunes qui aiment qu'on voit dans la
vidéo hors des témoins une dizaine
7,8 d'accord d'accord là on voit une
scène est ma le jeune qu'on voit se
faire frapper est venu avec deux copines
à lui d'accord ils passaient ils se sont
échangé des regards
et de là en fait le petit jeune il a dit
qu'est ce que vous avez à me regarder
suivent all-star ou quoi
on s'est un peu comment ça se passe
des rues des jeux de regards des
histoires un peu bête là il a dit ça ils
se sont un peu énervés il ya des mots
qui aurait été échangé des mots plus
durs
dans le groupe y en a toujours un qui va
un peu essayé de se démarquer faire un
peu ce culte ya des gros bras à celui
qui a énervé c'est parti de là et
malheureusement tous les autres ont
suivi après ça c'est triste de voir ce
genre de choses parce que ce sont des
comportements c'est vraiment pas normal
mais inadmissible c'est la mission du
d'accord parce que bon du petit lait
tout seul bien sûr ils sont six en face
c'est n'importe quoi on va pas se mentir
mais dans tous les cas même l'agression
en elle-même bien sûr pour un simple on
a parlé d'un combo fob alors que pas du
tout une wii en fait tout ça c'est parti
d'un truc vraiment bête hein raconte
c'est un psy il a marqué sur twitter il
avait mis une vidéo où quelqu'un on ne
sait pas c'est qu'ils convoient pas le
visage avant un rapport homosexuel
et il avait la vie densifier un artiste
je sais plus lequel est en dessous il a
mis aucun rapport mais ce n'est pas
parce qu'on est gay qu'on va se faire
taper par une bande de sauvages et l'a
mis la vidéo en dessous m sauf que la
vidéo en dessous étaient là juste pour
illustrer le fait de ne pas se faire
taper uniquement parce qu'on est gay
c'est d'accord ce n'était pas parce que
le jeune en question était gay lui même
ne savait pas encore il a été repris par
tous agression alors 5e pas du tout je
sais qui c'est entendu par la police un
seul jeune aujourd'hui il a bien dit que
ce n'était pas du tout une agression
homophobe
voilà et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ces
secousses et ce qui est toujours notée
une croix latine alors que tu nous dis
donc a priori d'après toi pas du tout on
était cinq fois
l'agression bon voilà en tout cas non
mais c'est bien utile à la mairie
histoire aussi non mais faut pas sortir
les choses du compte elle se trouve que
la scène est tellement sûre façon
l'agression elle est admissible quoi
qu'il arrive non je perds pas de
l'agression elle même se faire du fait
qu'on dise est déjà bien même des propos
qui sont tenus qui sont pas normales le
fait de dire un homosexuel blanc s'est
fait agresser par des jeunes noirs je
trouve que ce sont des propos
inadmissibles pas au mans il était blanc
mais on est sûr garçon n'a pas
simplement une fois devant la police n'a
pas n'a pas non pas du tout a eu peur
je ne pense pas
ça reste
surpris que toutes les rédactions moi
aussi face à tromper à ce point parce
qu'il paraît qu'il ya des mots échangés
comme [__] tout ça je suis juste resté
c'est une agression mais je suis
assez curieux nicolas dupont aignan où
ce que je veux juste dire d'abord c'est
abominable un reee portable il n'y a
aucune excuse pas parce qu'ils sont
jeunes ou pas je n'y a aucune excuse à
sa tâche qu'est lâchement un gamin comme
ça et moi ce que je sais j'ai appelé les
forces de police aujourd'hui c'est que
malgré tout
la victime
explique
n'a pas d'orientation sexuelle mais que
les insultes étaient bien homophobes
alors après voilà est-ce que quelle est
la part des choses moi je suis pas
policier mais je peux quand même vous
confirmer qu'il ya eu des insultes
homophobes ça c'est la réalité après jeu
on n'est pas flic on n'est pas juge mais
ce que je veux dire quand même
c'est ce qui s'est passé grâce à cette
vidéo parce que je vous entends des tout
à leur dire est ce qu'il faut punir ceux
qui filment bas il faut punir ceux qui
agressent pas bien c'est à l'heure et ça
c'est sûr s'il avait pas eu cette vidéo
donc donc toi tu ça date du 30 septembre
oui si avait pas eu cette vidéo n'était
pas au courant moi je suis le député de
la circonscription de l'est chaque année
cette rue parker je connais ce quartier
parker ci avait pas eu cette vidéo
personne l'aurait su oui mais ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire des trucs comme
ça il y en a partout sans arrêt et pas
simplement à montgeron donc vous pensez
que c'est bien de filmer
c'est pas bien de films et attendez
c'est pas bien et les vidéos c'est pas
bien mais pour s'en réjouir il s'en
féliciter et le faire comme un trophée
parce que c'est souvent ça mais en
revanche s'il n'y avait pas la liberté
de films et on n'aurait jamais su ce qui
s'était passé et depuis des années on
met le couvert sur la marmite on veut
pas dire ce qui se passe et j'ai eu
encore un habitant cet après midi
puisque je savais que je venais j'en ai
appelé un kabyle dans l'allée colbert et
qui m'a dit monsieur au delà des
problèmes de sécurité de justice et tous
dit bien que nous on n'en peut plus de
vivre là et que comme on est en logement
social on peut pas s'en aller qu'on vit
un enfer matin midi et soir à cause
d'une petite minorité qui se sent un peu
ni et qui terrorisent les habitants et
voyez ce que m'a dit la personne qui
habite ya une heure elle m'a dit surtout
dites bien que nous on est astreint
résidence et qu'on subit sa matin midi
et soir alors que ça c'est insupportable
en république alors si tu me dis je
comme dit guillaume loriot à mélanie mon
ami me dit que le témoin confirme que
ses agresseurs ont cru qu'ils étaient
homosexuels ont mis lui dit qu'il est
hétérosexuel donc oui mais ça c'est un
fait
mais problème c'est que dans ce genre
d'histoire il ya un nombre incalculable
de versions un nombre incalculable de
témoin qui dit avoir entendu en revanche
été bien finir là-dessus c'est fini nous
dans les cités font dans les quartiers
oui
[__] je dis je le dit vulgairement oui bd
tout ça ce sont des insultes ont quand
même se dire entre nous sale [__] autant
banaliser ça je suis d'accord mais c'est
pas spécialement au mont-fort c'est
parce que sa maman pour dire à quoi tu
es bien je te méprise c'est pas pour ça
n'a rien à voir ce n'est pas correct
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait de
maîtriser une personne dit à quelqu'un
vous en orientation sexuelle et ça c'est
en blanc sur lequel il faut vraiment
insister pour
rigoler c'est boris en fait c'est quoi
comment vous
c'est une insulte en fait n'est pas
méchamment nous c'est tellement banalisé
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure que
nous on ne voit pas méchamment on se le
dit comme ça il ya même des insultes
plus lourdes vais pas le dire en plateau
mais à des insultes plus l'eau qui se
disent pour rigoler en rigolant mais
venant de la part de personnes
extérieures ça va paraître choquant
alors que pour nous ce n'est pas
choquant moi j'étais moi aussi rires oui
on rien passé c'est vrai que faut
absolument pas banaliser ça mais par
contre c'est pas l'apanage des quartiers
moi j'ai grandi dans un village voilà on
était dégâts d'un milieu populaire aux
mobylettes les copains les filles de à
la maison les légats dehors il y avait
la même homophobie que j'avais des gens
qui faisaient le marché des
nouveaux arrivants où vous avez grandi
non c'est moi j'ai grandi dans des
milieux assez pauvre blanc creuse dans
la craie des bleus c'est vrai non mais
ça mais je peux par exemple
les eaux rien ce genre d' insulte ce
genre de ce côté en train de raconter
excuse moi je te tutoie j'ai vécu la
même chose quand j'avais 15 ans c'était
pas mal faut pas le banaliser faut le
condamner nation ce qu'on vient de voir
là c'est inadmissible traiter quelqu'un
de penne ça se fait pas et il faut
arrêter avec ça est vraiment est
d'ailleurs moi j'aimerais bien entendre
tous nos efforts aujourd'hui il est là
juste pour nous raconte
[Musique]
nino je dis moi j'ai vécu la même chose
j'ai pensé que ce qu'ils ont fait ce que
je voudrais pas que je n'aurais pas
c'est qu'on explique que l'homophobie ou
la violence c'est l'apanage des
quartiers leurs ballons mais j'ai
grandi à ce que je vais vous dire
quelque chose mes copains homosexuels
mes copines elle se faisait agresser et
c'était pas sympa du toit vivre quand on
était une fille de
m
dans la main il faut dire il faut le
lire
des cartes
j'ai grandi la violence contre les
homosexuels contre des jeunes femmes
mais vu de mes yeux et c'était pas une
cité c'est tout ce que j'ai c'est
curieux je lui est alors que vous avez à
dire j'ai juste à dire que bon déjà
juste effectivement la vidéo l m'a
traumatisée elle est très très dur à
regarder que ce soit la haine la
violence des coups portés
les hurlements de la victime mais
surtout le rire de ce garçon qui filme
qui est derrière la caméra les les rires
horrible qu'on entend ce que je remarque
c'est que dans les banlieues finalement
les premières victimes au delà des
personnes qui ont envie de vivre comme
des citoyens respectables ce sont avant
tout les minorités finalement les femmes
les juifs les homosexuels et les blancs
aujourd'hui les blancs parce que y'a
d'arcade dans certains quartiers
aujourd'hui les blancs sont minoritaires
c'est devenu un jeu qui est mort ya pas
longtemps en allant en sortant du foot
c'était pas
un juif ni c'était un jeune qui sortait
du foot on lui a demandé tu viens d'où
il a pris un coup de couteau il est mort
d'accord
donc il ya de la violence en
silence partout de nuire les femmes qui
se font agresser par des gens
viendraient la violence
d'origine ni de lieu la bce si vous ne
sais pas
ce qui est terrible c'est comme l'état
est défaillant là je vous ai amené tous
les collègues j'ai retrouvé que j'ai
adressé comme tous les ministres qui
passait sur ce quartier sur un autre
comme l'état est défaillant depuis des
années ça date pas de ce gouvernement
la police la justice tout le monde est
défaillant tout le monde s'en fout parce
que ce sont des quartiers malgré tout
relégué à l'abandon et bien après les
gens se divise alors tu es noir parce
que tu fais ça tu es blanc tu es ceci
c'est pas le problème le problème c'est
que ce sont des quartiers où l'état
laisse à loi de la jungle où une petite
minorité mais ce saut quoi à la forêt je
connais ce quartier parker l'aller
colbert je la connais ya de drogue
depuis des années la l'école berriacois
dans ce quartier je sais pas il ya 50
mecs qui foutent en l'air l'avis de 2000
habitants c'est 50 et encore 55 30 parce
qu'il n'ya pas autant écran non je vous
dis trafiquants et 25 ans et qu'on a
laissé depuis des années prendre de
l'ampleur y trafiquent qui terrorise eux
mais en fait la justice est complètement
impuissante ya eu une enquête ils en ont
arrêté là ça va mettre neuf mois ils
sont toujours pas incarcérer le 15 ans
par deux commerces et pas des barons du
trafic aux cibles
pourrir là ce que vous êtes en train de
nous dire là on innove c'est que il ya
cinquante jeunes à la forêt qui
terrorise tout un quartier et une salle
où nous sommes absents on est là on les
regards qu'on les laisse faire c'est ce
que vous êtes en train de dire
maintenant je suis désolé ça c'est la
preuve que vous mettez mon papier
vraiment dans une plaisante et je
connais la l'école lui même approché
c'est la principale ce qui s'y passe
que découvre bien là les français parce
que la forêt est devenue
numéro des gens qui n'en peuvent plus
admirer les données
qu'ils sont heureux de vivre alors forêt
mais oui qui sont tranquilles nicolas
dupont aignan monter leurs courses
nicolas
raison est vide et il arrive mais a
sorti une chose c'est la première vidéo
l'art il sort le carton synonyme je sais
pas combien d'années non mais hilario en
parler comme ça c'était bagdad et je
voudrais
il a raison je te dira tout ce qu'on
peut dire a tenu dans la grisaille de ma
région vit pris la raison il ya plein de
jeunes très bien mais heureusement
pourquoi ces jeunes très bien n'ont pas
le droit aussi de vivre tranquillement
dans leur quartier
pourquoi une assistante maternelle à sa
puce être brûlé en bas de en bas de
l'escalier parce que l a vu un
trafiquant de drogue pourquoi une petite
minorité a le droit de terroriser un
quartier camp mais considère toute la
jeunesse vous plaît pas on n'est pas
d'accord le changement n'est pas donnée
dont alexandre nous arrivons en forme
les quelques voyous qui nous plaît vous
faites partie de la jeunesse grande
différence entre défendre et dire ce qui
se passe réellement
je défends perd ses marines et de ils
défendraient jamais la violence moi je
ne sais quoi bein je sais juste en train
de vous dire que là vous êtes en train
d'en parler comme si waouh c'est la cité
non non non
mais c'est normal c'est pas normal
à 17 francs
et pouvait bien chaud
on n'a pas entendu ou policier candidats
d'après moi c'est ça parce que j'ai deux
casquettes celle ci policiers toujours
policier voilà et 15 ans d'expérience
jour est différent c'est exact c'est un
autre sujet mais ça marche aussi j'ai
pensé avant que le disant
le phénomène déjà la première chose
c'est la violence qui est pas admissible
quelles que soient les raisons le fait
que ce soient supposés ou pas son
homosexualité c'est pas un débat sur les
insulte homophobe c'est un fait
aggravant que ce soit vrai ou pas donc
on va rester sur la loi c'est du pénal
point c'est tout après le reste ça
aggrave où ça diminue la peine deuxième
chose les phénomènes où il ya des
agressions comme ça de bandes existe
depuis longtemps je suis rentré aux rg
il ya quinze ans il ya 15 ans l'énergie
nous montrer des vidéos donc là c'est
anecdotique c'était dans le xvième au
trocadéro mais c'est dans le cadre d'une
manifestation contre le cpu il ya 15 ans
donc c'est amusant voilà mais est bien
du coup y avait une queue de cortège là
pour le coup et il ya un jeune qui se
fait happer voilà là ils arrivent tous à
10 même chose il fracasse mais ce qui
est intéressant la vidéo continue ce
jeune se relève mais il l'aide à se
relever ils vont fracassé un autre et un
effet de meute qui tape le plus faible
et c'est ça la difficulté et on arrive à
quelque chose ou pour un regard les gens
vont s'entretuer de taper dessus il ya
une démission de l'école d'un moment
avec le dialogue avec l'éducation
l'éducation n'est plus dans les
banlieues on en voit on me renvoyait les
meilleurs profs on envoie les sorties
d'école même chose pour la police
montréal est sortie d'école c'est trop
facile
c'est pas preuve alors qu'ils étaient en
enfance aux parents des salons je vois
bien sûr quelque chose de cassé j'ai
bien
sûr une anecdote il a raison les
analystes parlent de
toi ô ya une anecdote effectivement sur
ça oui je fais différentes couches et
sur l'éducation les deux sont importants
sur l'instruction l'éducation déconne je
vais vraiment collègues en entier dans
les années 2000 dans certains quartiers
difficiles et un jour l'anecdote c'est
un copain qui avait trois jours qui
était dans la police il entend sur les
ondes règlement de comptes dans la cité
la bac est pris à partie tir de
flash-ball qu'on ne jette pas vu de
l'autre côté ils arrivent idei et ont
garé la voiture entre les deux là mon
copain m'a dit on va se faire tuer du
côté de la police on a dit arrêtez de
tirer elle est calé au milieu du côté de
la cité il ouvre la porte le policier
arrêté de tirer c'est gérard parce qu'il
connaissait il dit voilà moi je sais où
ils sont il dit c'est pas le problème il
ya un contrôle d'identité car elle tend
et une identité de qui de lui de lui
voilà les identités il a dit moi quand
il ya quelqu'un qui fait du scooter sans
casque dans la cité justement je vais
pas l'emmener je vais sonner chez les
parents j'ai pas le poursuivre et les
parents generali régler le prince était
l'assistante sociale il ya des choses en
fait de travail de proximité où tout le
monde a son rôle à jouer
vraiment je suis terrible parce que hier
j'entends madame le maire de cette ville
qui dit oh c'est une agression comme il
peut y en avoir d'autres j'entends ce
jeune homme qui dit ça on se traite de
paix dès 10 h chez nous ça veut rien
dire j'entends monsieur dires abat dans
les deux sets quand j'étais jeune
oui non non ça va
si on dit à l'elysée
de l'agression alléguée propose de
replacer à fait aggravant c'est bien
fait aggravant [__] ya 40%
d'augmentation chaque année d'agression
c'est comme le racisme c'est parti grave
nous plaise ses portes à leur tour safox
ix et sos homophobie il vient de me dire
que la victime a accepté d'être
accompagné par eux c'est donc une
agression à caractère homophobe merci
mobile jour dit aussi que plusieurs mois
dans un quartier
savait mieux
fait tellement bien
des manières le problème et c'est un
sujet hyper compliqué sans être
stigmatisés sans faire d'amalgamé merci
mathieu nokia est le plus besoin c'est
nino oui mais monsieur tâche est
complètement à côté de la plaque est
dans un déni idéologique mais qui fait
peur est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu
un qui sait que dans le déni mais vous
avez des homosexuels en banlieue est ce
que vous connaissez livre exemple
dans les gares et vauvert j'en connais
dans les quartiers
[Musique]
je sais quand les gens du manioc riz
l'homophobie dans les quartiers monsieur
taché est ce que c'est une réalité
ailleurs madame c'est
une réalité
régulièrement tous les jours de plus en
plus et c'est dès qu'il l'aura au ps
vous voulez absolument essentiel
aura la tâche et gérer des maillots on
arrête les deux ça y est stop au plus
bas on voulait en venir dans mais c'est
bon mais pas sur votre chemin my soul et
rock ni dormir alexis lorieux voisine et
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit oui
l'homophobie peut exister dans les
quartiers absolument comme parent mais
peut exister partout mais beaucoup dans
les quartiers en ce moment je suis pas
emballé par le quartier du mondial non
mais c'est parce qu'à force de dire
partout c'est là qu'on la banalise
examens blancs et noirs regarder ce
qu'il ya dans ce cas là je prône le mal
j'ai bien dit monsieur dupont s'en
foutent
m
moi je vote
politique juste terminer sur ça dans mon
sang mon quartier je veux mon quartier
comme exemple regarder
des homosexuels vivent très bien leur
vie en fait non pas de problème donc
pourquoi parler de basket
action là si vous voulez si vous voulez
dire que ces sessions homophobes
franchement je voulais c'est parce que
moi je sais on connaît la vérité on le
sait que c'est pas une ses patrouilles à
caractère homophobe mais juste le but
c'est de dénoncer la violence qui est
qui est là et qu'on voit c'est ça le
problème c'est pas le fait que ce soit
je ne sais quoi je ne sais quoi passant
de 24 ans qui sortait de la rue mais le
truc c'est que ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que vous parler de l'homophobie
des quartiers comme si vous vivez dans
tous les quartiers de france comme si
vous saviez avec vos chiffres mais voici
que c'est pas la phobie quartier sera
terminée vous parler d'éducation valeurs
d'éducation c'est aussi ne pas couper la
parole aux gens qu'on va au filet je
veux finir là-dessus
comme ça c'est pas méchant
il ya des personnes homosexuelles dans
le quartier qui vivent très bien ils
sortent ils marchent ils vont ils font
leurs vieux heureusement
c'est un quartier homophobe mais on n'a
pas dit
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que regarder
il ya des on est pas tous pareils ok
vous vous accepter certaines choses vous
le prenez de vote façon il y en a
malheureusement ils n'ont pas la même
intelligence ça veut dire qu'ils vont
avoir des réactions qu'ils sont bêtes et
méchantes et ça ok on condamne tous mais
le problème c'est quoi c'est que là on
en parle on en parle mais vous
stigmatisez la jeune et dans le quartier
le 6 et moi le premier j'ai désolé il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas là
nous croyons le problème c'est pas ça le
problème c'est qu'en laissant pourrir la
situation en laissant des agressions se
faire
agresser homophobes un coup agression
antisémite de l'autre coup agression
ceci dans des quartiers qui sont
abandonnées s'il y avait ça dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris il y aurait une
enquête policière il y aurait
immédiatement la justice serait traité
en ces mois
trois femmes - des policiers par
habitant trois fois moins dans la
circonscription dont je suis le député
depuis 20 ans trois fois moi j'ai écrit
à tous les ministres deuxièmement il ya
vingt greffiers qui sont pas au palais
de justice d'evry les affaires prennent
des des mois avant d'être traité au nom
de quoi parce qu'on habite un quartier
difficile qu'on soit blanc noir jaune
vert de telle religion et où on doit
vivre en insécurité et au nom de quoi on
nie le problème la politique de
l'autruche ça fait vingt ans ça
s'aggrave parce que vous en avez certain
qu'ils savent qu'ils peuvent trafic et
pillé tabasser on parle des trucs
homophobes on parle pas des violences
conjugales j'ai vu dans la presse un
monsieur jette sa femme par la fenêtre
incroyable six mois avec sursis voilà la
réalité du pays un trafiquant de drogue
en dans le collège lycée professionnel
de ma ville des couteaux comme ça juste
après les rixes où il ya eu un mort à
boussy-saint-antoine y en a eu deux en
essonne la justice textuel le procureur
et le préfet des ateliers récréatifs des
changes intercar oui et le tribunal cinq
mois avec sursis et vous mais non non
mais il est devenu dark à je suis désolé
non mais est ce que vous trouvez
attendait le problème est là et après
qu'est ce qui arriva alors que les gens
se dressent les uns contre les autres
thés noirs des jaunes et ceci au
sexuelle parce que l'état n'est plus là
républicain est temps qu'on remettra pas
de l'adar nikolov ferme prison dégage tu
laisses le quartier vivre tu trafiques
tu dégages le tout voilà comme suis
désolé il y aura la concorde non
meilleur à la concorde et on m'a rappelé
une histoire de race d'histoire de deux
sexes d'histoire de ceux-ci juliette
qu'on a pas ou quand la république n'est
pas l'art c'est la division oui il ya la
division alès parlé là elle y est je
suis vraiment désolé il ya aussi un
problème de culture et laissez moi aller
jusqu'aux remets toi père sont là dessus
oui je suis à fond là dessus on est
quartier coutume associé à 2019 63% et
musulmans perçoivent l'homosexualité
comme une maladie ou une paire naissant
sexuelle contre cadeaux
les banques même si toutes
les violences contre les homosexuels
sont compréhensibles compte 9 % des
catholiques qui
vous allez voter eric zemmour oui
mais
eric zemmour et de l'homosexualité cette
ingérence a fait ça c'est la firme
un
truc là vous allez dans un débat
interminable dans lequel vous n'avez
aucune connaissance et à des barrages de
vous dire vous parlez de choses dont
vous n'avez pas connaissance dans la vie
il faut parler avec ses connaissances et
de l'édition vous parler de chiffres
mais excusez moi c'est quel genre de
demandes d'interviews vsig mois
[Applaudissements]
cela vous dit une grosse connerie
désolé je m'en fous de ce que ça
complexe et heureuse d'accord en restant
vous êtes musulman à des gens qui ont
vraiment la science vous parlez de
gentils la plupart des musulmans disent
chacun ça dit ok chacun sa vie chacun
son chemin ça c'est au tour david
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de l'ifa
les homosexuels étaient lâchés et
maltraités on nous parle de sa
jeune histoire de
[Musique]
finir
à la foule
merci à tout
d'abord à brno ni l'eau ni mentalement
ni
rodez bat
chauny
mon prix en général
alexandre l'endroit ta3 sujet ce soir
qui sont mélangés premier sujet c'est le
problème de la violence qui a laissé
faire et qui a une démission des
pouvoirs plus parfait et il aime ça a
été enregistrée par emmanuel macron qu'a
dit on va faire des quartiers de
reconquête républicaine il dit dans
quelques années on va s'occuper de ces
quartiers donc ça pose un problème et
pour le trafic de drogue un numéro vert
et je pense au numéro 91 parce que j'ai
eu à faire dirige châtillon les
policiers étaient utilisés pour
surveiller une caméra de surveillance du
toc de régler le poème du trafic de
drogue donc les policiers sont capables
de faire leur travail encore faut-il que
ya des gens qui sont au niveau politique
donc ça c'est sûr les violences le
trafic sur l'homosexualité l'homophobie
un autre sujet là c'est un problème
national on doit traiter partout en
mettant les moyens où il ya plus de
problématiques mais c'est pas on doit
pas se réduire à des endroits nidaki par
la mcc
la troisième sujet le troisième sujet
c'est oublier pas parce que tu souhaites
président
fasciné les épouvantails nation dit
c'est de la faute de telles communautés
de telles choses c'était il ya deux
solutions en france il ya ceux qui
respectent la loi et ceux qui ne la
respectent pas ça prend un peu de
n'importe quelle couleur on peut être de
n'importe quelle religion la question
ces délinquants ou criminels un an mais
à partir de là beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
je pense que là c'est pas écrit sur le
visage je suis musulman c'est pas écrit
ça se voit on voit même pas qui c'est
qui la chaleur des allées un peu
sadiques champion du monde à se parler
nico ce débat
arrive au plus bas s'est passé tellement
d'accord avec monsieur lacroix sam
langlois
[Applaudissements]
celanese
des produits détergents la
base et au sénat
[Rires]
ça montre bien que quand on laisse
pourrir un problème on arrive à dn
absurde et là je suis pas d'accord avec
vous ce que je fais là que si vous
voulez ce mot-là
[Musique]
sur vous et vous vous êtes une dingue
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire je vous dis
josé cola avait lu que ce quartier et de
cette circonscription depuis 20 ans et
je peux vous dire de quoi ces candidats
présents et je suis dit gino savard et
je vais dire une chose j'aurais pu dire
je connais les enfants de ce quartier où
plus émoussé tu me suis donné les
enfants que
deux bombes alors oui je connais les
enfants de ce quartier et j'accepte pas
sur les salissent tous parce qu'il ya
des élèves de leur côté je veux qu'on
leur tape dessus quand ils sont
délinquants peuvent en revanche en
prison mais en revanche accepte pas
concerner toute une génération s'est
animée comme vous le faites ça c'est
dégueulasse